más de 62 mil familias afectadas esa es
la cifra que el viceministerio de
defensa civil de bolivia calcula que ha
dejado el temporal de lluvias que azota
el país la ciudad de la paz ha sido una
de las más golpeadas en donde las
autoridades reportaron al menos un
fallecimiento y varios desaparecidos
en el barrio de los rosales al sur de la
capital múltiples casas quedaron
gravemente dañadas anteanoche dar yo vi
tan fuerte como arriba ha bajado de
aquel canaletas como una destilación
brecha así la dejó siembras botado nos
ha asustado grave no hemos dormido dos
noches no hay más tormes la alcaldía
anunció que se encuentra de muriendo de
manera controlada varias viviendas del
barrio que podrían colapsar debido a los
deslizamientos para carga está bien a
navegación pero como es la alturas
pronunciadas
cuando el
prácticamente nos dormimos hace 3 días
los daños causados por la lluvia se han
dado en ocho de los nueve departamentos
del país y la mayoría se encuentra en
alerta meteorológica naranja con riesgo
medio debido a que se prevé que las
lluvias continúen es que en este periodo
estamos sufriendo por el fenómeno en la
niña lo que está un poco
condicionando los eventos climatológicos
y se están caracterizando en su mayoría
por eventos muy cortos con una
intensidad extremadamente alta las
precipitaciones también han dejado 33
mil hectáreas de cultivos dañadas y
cerca de 700 53 viviendas afectadas